il y a un peu plus d'un an ils vont
colonnes a été victime donc d'une
agression en détention qui allait lui
coûter la vie ils vont Calonne était
comme son agresseur détenu à la maison
centrale d'Arles le statut détenu
particulièrement signalé auquel il
continue d'être soumis ayant toujours
empêché son rapprochement pratique
encore au sein de l'établissement de
bord
monsieur le Premier ministre en raison
de l'obligation de déport à laquelle
était et reste astreint le garde des
sceaux mais à la fois le dernier
responsable politique avoir maintenu le
statut déterminé Patrick Clément signalé
divan colonne et le premier le seul à
l'avoir levé par la force des choses il
y a un enjeu pour jour le 8 mars 2022
dans les circonstances que l'on sait
désormais le statut de dps de messieurs
alessandry et Ferrand il sera levé
quelques jours plus tard le 11 mars
cette décision bien évidemment interroge
évidemment même si dans le cas de
monsieur Alexandre Ferrand nous pouvons
que nous réjouir de ce qu'elle aura
permis enfin le rapprochement familial
encore c'est par suite par des sciences
justice des aménagements de peine et en
conduit à leur projet de semis liberté
mais évidemment nous sommes là dans le
cas de commission d'enquête pour revoir
refaire l'histoire de ce qui s'est passé
je serai tenté de dire de deux choses
l'une soit premier hypothèse les membres
du commando d'irinhac satisfaisait
objectivement aux critères dps au niveau
de leur dangerosité notamment parce que
c'est cela qui nous occupe alors en
faisant preuve de la même rigueur
évoquée jusqu'à ce jour devant cette
commission notamment pour les
administrations qui ont eu à répondre
sur cette question et politique
concernée ils auraient dû rester soumets
ce statut même en dépit de l'agression
en suivant ce fil de rigueur pour
barbares qu'elle était l'agression du
vancolone ne constituait pas une sorte
d'ardoise magique à cet égard puisque à
ce moment là le comportement des
tensions le profil les risques réels ou
supposés associés à ces détenus non pas
évidemment subitement de changer après
le 2 mars si le considérait vraiment les
analyses précédentes
soit second hypothèse il ne satisfaitait
pas totalement aux critères
initiatisfaisait plus et dans ce cas
évidemment on peut s'interroger combien
depuis combien de temps ils étaient
alors en réalité maintenu sous ce statut
pour les raisons souvent n'ont pas
objectif mais politique étrangère à la
seule et stricte application du droit
ce que j'ai appelé même si aucun aurait
pu ont pu considérer ces propos durs la
vengeance d'État les concernant lors de
la question au gouvernement que je vous
ai adressée directement concernant le
nécessaire rapprochement en Corse et
leur demande d'aménagement de peine en
particulier 19 octobre 2021 soit 5 mois
avant l'effet il n'y a pas pour nous ici
à ce stade pour l'instant de troisième
voie
on peut évidemment comprendre la levée
du statut dps qu'elle était décidée
après l'agression pour des raisons
politiques afin de favoriser
l'apaisement
mais si la levée a été décidé pour les
raisons politiques cela ne fait-il pas
que ce statut avait été maintenu pour
des raisons politiques également et
depuis combien de temps on ne peut pas
ne pas l'envisager vous savez que nous
sommes pour certains d'entrelorgements
convaincus comme de nombreuses personnes
surtout la lumière de certains
précédents lourdes de sens vous n'étiez
pas en fonction mais comme par exemple
la fausse réunion du commission locale
dps dans le cas du vent colonne à Toulon
2011 jusqu'à mis en exergue les
contentieux autrement au niveau du
tribunal administratif de Toulon 2012 où
le revirement de position soudain de la
commission locale dps de Poissy en 2022
concernant monsieur alessandres
j'insiste et nous savons tous
la situation est le profil les
intéressés dans leur parcours carcéral
n'avait pas changé comme par magie du
fait de l'agression au-delà de ce sujet
nous sauterons entre autres questions
évidemment vous interrogez sur la prison
de borgues Messieurs poupon et kettle
récemment additionné ont affirmé que des
échanges politiques réguliers avaient eu
lieu
entre vous-même votre cabinet vous
conseiller et les élus de la Corse et
qui portaient notamment sur les
aménagements apportés à ces
établissements pour ces détenus pour
qu'il puisse être accueillis par
transfert tout comme sur la question de
la levée de statut de dps vous devez cet
égard venir encore centre fin 2021
2000-2022 confirmer cela selon les
propos
comme l'engagement d'ailleurs du
gouvernement sur d'autres sujets
des marchés auraient été passés des
travaux engagés donc nous allons
évidemment vous demander si vous
confirmez ces échanges politiques et le
début de réalisation de ces travaux
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier ministre mes chers collègues
à ce stade je ne poserai pas de
questions ni
la Commission dans un propos introductif
trop long et je laisse le Président
vous faire prêter serment monsieur le
Premier ministre
merci Monsieur rapporteur comme il est
d'usage je me suis le premier ministre
en application l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance numéro 58-1100 du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires je vais
vous demander de prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité je vous prie d'activer votre
micro de lever la main droite et de dire
je le jure je le jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
pour une dizaine de minutes merci
pierre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président j'ai écouté évidemment avec
beaucoup d'attention votre intervention
liminaire j'avais reçu je le dis devant
la commission d'enquête de la part du
rapporteur déjà un certain nombre de
questions alors juste en termes de
méthode pour ne pas avoir à répéter deux
fois la même chose préférez-vous
m'interroger directement à partir des
questions que vous m'avez transmises ou
est-ce que vous souhaitez que j'y
réponds de directement et notamment
suite à l'intervention du Président je
me mets à votre disposition si vous
choisissez les termes de votre exposé
les mineurs monsieur bon alors
les sujets sur lesquels le vous
m'interrogez comme vous l'avez fort bien
dit monsieur le Président j'ai eu en
connaître dans le cadre de décret de
déport
vous connaissez l'origine il y en a eu
très précisément deux le premier est
intervenu le 23 octobre 2020 et visait
la situation de monsieur Yvan colonne le
deuxième est intervenu le 17 décembre de
cette même année 2020 et concernait la
situation de Monsieur
Alessandri et Ferrandi
pour que les choses soient très claires
j'ai eu à intervenir dans ce dossier en
application du décret de déport à deux
reprises dans chacune de ces deux
situations je commence oui bien par
Monsieur Colonna puisque c'est le sujet
majeur de de cette commission d'enquête
si j'ai bien compris donc
j'ai eu un statuer en réalité vous le
voyez vous l'avez sans doute récupéré
dans le dossier dame et messieurs les
députés le directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire agissant sur ma délégation
le 6 août 2021 pour répondre à la
demande formulée par l'intéressé de
lever de son statut de DBS et
effectivement comme vous l'avez dit
monsieur le Président
j'ai opposé une décision de refus
je tiens à dire tout de suite et de la
façon plus nette certainement pas pour
des raisons politiques pas plus que je
ne changerai ma décision pour des
raisons politiques enfin en tout cas
faudrait s'entendre sur la portée du mot
politique parce que quelque part tout
est politique mais je l'ai fait dans un
dossier extrêmement difficile au vu des
avis rendus moi c'est une procédure je
vous l'avoue que j'ai découverte à cette
occasion celle des déplaises je me suis
renseigné le décret fixant cette liste
la circulaire prise pour son application
qui je crois d'octobre 2012 donc j'ai
constaté que une commission compétente
institue au sein de l'administration
pénitentiaire avait été réunis à ami un
avis évidemment que j'ai lu de manière
approfondie je m'en souviens à l'époque
la vie je crois aussi du parquet
national anti-terroriste les deux
étaient défavorables à la demande ex par
Monsieur colonne
notamment parce que
le la période de sûreté qui entourait la
sanction pénale qu'il avait frappé
n'était que très récemment échu
qu'ensuite parce que il y avait eu avant
son arrestation
des
phénomènes de fuite et je rappelle que
le fait de dire on maintient un statut
de dps c'est pour précisément renforcer
la surveillance à l'égard de intéressés
et enfin parce que il y avait eu si j'ai
bien lu et vous l'avez sûrement dossier
différents incidents disciplinaires qui
s'étaient produits pendant la période
récente d'incarcération bref j'ai suivi
la recommandation de la Commission et
j'ai donc pris le
6 août 2021 très précisément
la décision de rejet
il a été fait un recours contre cette
décision je ne suis pas sûr d'ailleurs
qu'il était jugé avant les fêtes agit
que du mois de mars 2022 en revanche je
fais observer mais sans doute cette tel
à la commission que s'agissant de la
décision précédente
de refus de lever du statut de dps qui
avait été prise par le la précédente
garde des sceaux il n'y avait pas alors
de décret de déport le tribunal
administratif de Marseille et l'avait
rejeté par décision du 21 janvier 2022
enfin avait rejeté le recours pardon
fait par Monsieur colonne et si je le
cite c'est que j'ai regardé la
motivation de la décision que j'ai prise
et la décision prise antérieurement
était assez proche donc
supposer qu'il y aurait la même décision
bon alors voilà c'est pour des motifs de
fêtes
Premier ministre applique les textes
qu'ils mettent apparu
nécessaire de maintenir ce statut pour
Monsieur Kona et j'ai entendu je l'avais
lu aussi
la notion de vengeance d'État je le dis
très clairement devant cette commission
et dans le cadre des prérogatifs qui
étaient les miennes associés il n'y a
jamais eu à aucun cas la recherche de
vengeance d'État mais l'application de
texte bon
la foi suivante je suis toujours sur la
situation de Monsieur colon
la commission la même commission
était appelée si mes informations sont
exactes à se réunir le 8 mars 2022 pour
examiner la nouvelle demande de levée de
dps formé par Monsieur Colin et c'est là
qui est arrivé que sont arrivés les
fêtes agiques du 2 mars donc
effectivement
je vous confirme que pour des raisons
humanitaires pose la question quelles
sont les deux hypothèses ici il y en a
une troisième
pour des raisons humanitaires j'ai levé
le statut de dps de Monsieur Colonna
après l'assurance de ces faits je dois
ajouter du point de vue administratif
que
cet acte tout à fait barbare a été
victime de l'intéressé mais à occasionné
chez moi beaucoup de perplexité sur la
nature de ce statut
des PS
des tenues particulièrement signalées
particulièrement surveillé il y a
effectivement de quoi se poser des
questions d'où l'enquête que j'ai
demandé immédiatement le lendemain même
des fins à l'inspection générale de la
justice mais le motif immédiatement qui
a été le mien pour prendre cette
décision monsieur le Président Mesdames
et c'est celui-là
et
pardon de m'arrêter parce que j'aurais
dû recommencer la chronologie mais
ayant pour ces motifs levés le statut de
dps de Monsieur Colonna il me semblait
en mon âme et conscience extrêmement
difficile compte tenu de la hiérarchie
des responsabilités dans les faits dans
les corrélation de maintenir celui de
Monsieur Ferrandi alessandrie compte
tenu aussi mais je crois le monsieur
Perrin que vous l'avez vous-même évoqué
des questions de troubles à l'ordre
public avant de maintien de l'ordre
public républicain puisque évidemment
l'effet perpétré contre Monsieur Colonna
qui conduira à son décès quelques jours
après
avait suscité légitimement beaucoup
d'émotions bon donc c'est cet
enchaînement et ces motifs là qui m'ont
conduit à prendre les décisions que j'ai
prises et que j'assume totalement devant
vous s'agissant je reviens donc en
arrière pour messieurs alessandrie
Ferrandi je n'avais eu à connaître de
leur situation de demande d'exposer par
une fois
qu'une fois je le rappelle une décision
du 12 janvier
2021 précisément
qui elle aussi en tout cas sinon sur le
fond en tout cas sur la forme a été
confirmé pardon par une ordonnance du
juge des référés du tribunal de
Versailles intervenu le 31 janvier 2022
bon jugement assez long pour un référé
il existe pour les mêmes motifs que ce
indiqué précédemment pour Monsieur
Colonna et après je n'ai plus eu à
connaître du sujet jusqu'à la décision
que j'ai prise encore une fois
postérieurement à
comment dire l'agression dont avait été
victime monsieur Colin donc voilà pour
l'enchaînement des faits et puisque j'ai
un comprendre c'est de votre décision
les fondements
[Musique]
octobre 2021 il savait là aussi cette
décision avait donné lieu à un certain
nombre de commentaires notamment dans à
l'Assemblée de Corse donc voilà si vous
voulez le cadre et les réponses précises
que je peux faire sur cet enchaînement
de circonstances et voulez-vous que je
parle de Borgo maintenant ou voulez-vous
revenir sur ces faits précis d'abord
monsieur le Président on va revenir pour
ce qui me concerne ensuite je passerai
la parole à Monsieur rapporteur qu'elle
est question si à vous poser puis on
reviendra effectivement sur Borgo
ensuite et bon votre propos m'amène
plusieurs questions rapides
monsieur le Premier ministre
vous dites à l'instar évidemment que
d'autres acteurs qui sont venus nous qui
n'avaient pas de logique de vengeance
concernant ces détenus comme on nous a
expliqué ici à plusieurs reprises qui
n'est pas de gestion particulière tout
en nous disant je cite je parle d'autres
acteurs qui sont venus devant nous qui
avaient quand même un procès particulier
concernant les tenues basses et Corse
parce que pour des raisons plus larges
je ne cite pas la personne qui l'a dit
devant l'audition mais c'est une
responsable politique éminent
dont acte nous connaissons évidemment
les critères de l'instruction
ministérielle du statut dps en question
et je pars à fraiserais encore une
nouvelle fois le rapporteur de
commission seront un petit peu blasés de
l'entendre mais c'est une réalité qui
est évoquée dans ses travaux les propos
du directeur administration
pénitentiaire lui-même devant cette
commission sur les six critères évoqués
3 concerne gestion directe
administration pénitentiaire au sens de
la véracité de l'analyse de parcours
carcéral des individus et en l'espèce le
drame nous amène à considérer le
parcours en miroir de deux individus
dont l'un avait je cite un parcours
qualifié de correct voir très correct
sur sa longueur sur son longue des
tensions et l'autre un parcours
chaotique dangereux etc n'a pas moins
que l'on fait la photographie entre le
gestion clémente d'un cas et la gestion
rigoureuse de latte de l'autre puisque
les trois autres critères d'excitent le
directeur association pénitentiaire
concernait d'autres acteurs qui
décidaient évidemment en raison du
procès en raison de situation pénale de
départ autrement dit quel était
l'évolution du parcours carcaire
l'individu des trois premiers critères
ou un des trois premiers critères
suffisait
à maintenir le statut pour des acteurs
qui ne voulaient pas se reposer sur
l'évolution de parcours carcéral bon
d'ailleurs
ce que vous citez comme élément
d'analyse des commissions locales sont
les mêmes que l'on soit en 2021 en 2020
en 2018 en 2011 ou en 2012 il y a eu
l'épisode que je vous ai évoqué du
contentieux ou le tribunal administratif
de Toulon 1er instance puis la cour
administrative d'appel de Marseille
donne raison aux avocats colonnes pour
sur l'excès de pouvoir avec la fausse
commission locale des PS fabriquée à
Toulon indiqué par trimland serait-il de
Toulon pour le seul exemple qui était
mis en exergue de cette attitude on l'a
mis de l'ingénierie en capacité de nuire
c'est pas moi qui parle c'est le
tribunal administratif de Toulon donc on
connaît cette capacité à répondre sur
les critères néanmoins il se confrontent
au parcours carcéral de réaliser
l'individu et vous le savez qu'à ce
moment-là Monsieur le Premier Ministre
des demandes sociétales démocratiques
importantes demandez à lever statut dps
non pas pour
mythifier ou mettre en exergue le statut
en tant que tel mais tout simplement
parce qu'il est administrativement un
empêchement rapprochement familial
c'était la question du rapprochement
familial qui était importante c'était
pas le statut en lui-même autrement dit
un second temps s'il y avait eu des
aménagements peu coûteux du centre
équation de bord tout en étant dps ce
qui comptait c'est qu'il soit rapprochés
tu égard à la longue distance je
rappelle quand même qu'ils vont colonnes
vous voyez pas sa mère depuis 15 ans qui
ne voyait plus son jeune fils depuis
trois ans ils sont pas malades donc
c'est factuels ce sont des réalités
factuelles pour lui comme des autres de
tenues donc la question est-elle le
rapprochement familial tel que demander
politiquement
d'un point de vue humanitaire là-dessus
bon vous dites qui est pas de vengeance
ou qui a pas eu de gestion politique
nous permettrait de faire un dernier
point là dessus
vous êtes vous prenez la décision
concernant pierre-alessandre vous avez
parlé donc de janvier 2021
mais vous la prenez après que la
commission locale des pièces de Poissy
dans un avis favorable à la levée
autrement dit dans un des cas ils vont
colonne vous nous citera juste titre sur
la question des cycles des 6 critères
dps le fait que la commission locale
pour les raisons vous avez invoqué donne
un indice défavorable à la levée dans
l'autre des cas le cas qui est le cas
que je viens de citer la commission
locale dps on en a vite favorable et
c'était le troisième avis favorable à la
levée de statut de dps de pierre à
Alexandre pour autant
vous donner une décision négative à un
moment un peu paroxétique nous sommes en
décembre 2020 de janvier 2021 où vous
aviez été destinataire d'émotions
d'assemblée de Corse
vous ne pouvez pas le pas connaître la
tribune des six groupes parlementaires
qui avaient demandé l'apaisement de ce
dossier des commandes de réglage jusqu'à
6 groupes parlementaires si une tribune
dans Le Monde donc la question je vous
la pose directement vous étiez détenteur
de pouvoir réglementaire donc politique
et évidemment vous n'étiez pas lié aux
commissions dans aucun des cas ni dans
un sens la preuve en est ni dans l'autre
d'ailleurs puisque c'est vous l'avez
démontré vous l'avez démontré il y avait
pas d'avilier pour autant vous avez pris
un avis négatif à un moment qui est un
moment charnière
donc moi je vous pose la question
qu'est-ce qui a fondé votre avis est-ce
que d'autres experts d'autres
commissions nationales sont venus vous
dire qu'il fallait malgré la commission
d'experts locale qui avait donné pour la
troisième fois
pour la troisième fois un moment où
c'était très important
qu'est-ce qui a fondé en indice
scientifique et politique votre avis bon
et ça m'amène évidemment vous poser la
question est-ce que
la prégnance de l'acte pour lequel c'est
détenu avait été condamné celle
d'assassinat d'un préfet de la
République n'a-t-il pas pesé trop dans
votre décision à ce moment-là comme je
vous mets à l'aise comme d'autres
premiers ministres ou d'autres gardent
les sauts avant vous d'accord je parle
de manière structurelle dans la
continuité de l'État sur ce dossier
est-ce que vous avez été amené à
rencontrer la les parties civils la
famille eriniaque sur ce dossier
inquiète ou pas de rapprochement de
l'aménagement de peine avez-vous échangé
sur ce dossier pour prendre cette
décision là avec les cabinets de
l'Elysée ce sont les questions que l'on
s'est posé que l'on se pose parce que il
faut aujourd'hui solder se passer cette
histoire il faut regarder le passé parce
que nous sommes face à une affaire grave
par de l'assassinat même si c'est pas
lié à l'assassinat directement dans les
faits selon ton parle
le fait est que s'il y avait une gestion
un peu plus anticipée du rapprochement
et Van colonne peut-être sera vivant et
certainement aujourd'hui donc ça c'est
une réalité qui est liée elle n'est pas
liée au fait mais les liée
consécutivement à la capacité ou non
d'avoir pu réaliser des actes en temps
et en heure donc c'est la question je
vous pose à l'eau de ce que je viens des
deux questions que je vous pose à l'eau
ne ce que je viens de vous évoquer
concernant le fait que vous n'avez pas
suivi la commission locale dps de Poissy
en 2020
oui alors d'abord
vos premières questions concernées
monsieur Colonna quand j'ai eu affaire
aux avis relatifs à la levée du statut
de dps de Monsieur colonne tout les avis
était négatifs vous dites si j'avais
pris une décision différente il aurait
pas été assassiné à voir là l'ordre on
va loin pardonnez-moi de vous le dire
bon je reviens en premier cas
dans les éléments que j'ai à l'époque
non je ne vous dis tout de suite je n'ai
pas rencontré les parties civils enfin
j'ai pas eu de contact extérieur je
regarde le dossier à mon âme et
conscience je regarde il y a un avis du
parquet national anti-terroriste qui est
négatif à la levée de ce statut le
dossier m'arrive le décret de déport est
récent et je considère que compte tenu
des éléments ma possession il n'y a pas
lieu de faire droit à cette demande
point et j'ai pas c'est une décision que
je prends moi-même voyons clairs puisque
c'est la question que vous me posiez
là ce n'est plus les avis négatifs comme
sur local les avis sont positifs pour la
levée de statut oui alors il y a pour le
maintien il y a effectivement un avis
mais
là j'ai pas le dossier soi-même je crois
que la Commission a changé son avis
soyons c'est très important non ce que
je vous dis factuel la commission locale
dps de Poissy en 2020 donne un avis
positif pour la troisième fois
consécutive parce que vous vous êtes pas
censé ça
et je garde un souvenir d'un avis
défavorable du parquet national
le droit à la matière vous avez un avis
vous avez un avis de commission locale
vous avez dans un écran on l'a bien
entendu le cas divan colonne que vous
avez suivi la vie vous n'étiez pas lié
vous l'avez suivi vous nous l'expliquez
contact dans le cas que je vous oppose
qui est le cas contraire vous avez pris
un avis réglementaire politique à
l'inverse une commission locale dps qui
avait décidé dans un moment important de
lever le statut de dps de Pierre
Allessandre pour la troisième fois
consécutive donc on s'explique mal et on
voudrait avoir des éclaircissements sur
ce process qui vous a été amené à
prendre un avis contraire puisque par
ailleurs vous dites suivre le commission
locale
il était défavorable à la à la levée
donc favorable au rejet c'est le
souvenir que j'ai maintenant moi j'ai
plus les pièces sur moi si vous les avez
ah oui je vous confirmez et en tout cas
je vous confirme de l'intervention du
parquet national anti-terroriste
défavorable à la levée donc au vu de ses
commissions LPS donc c'est vrai donc au
vu de ces éléments je me c'est un peu
vieux pour moi mais je me souviens bien
que en conscience j'ai pris la décision
de ne pas vous avez souvenir que le
parquet est intervenu il me semble oui
bon c'est très important ce que vous
dites parce que là comme la vie était
favorable si le parc est intervenu ça
pose une problématique particulière qui
est sensible puisque le parquet est mis
en cause vous le savez dans l'inspection
de la justice pour son rôle dans le
poste sententiel concernant notamment le
parcours de Langa B donc ça pose des
questions je je non mais je vous donne
des éléments
Monsieur le Premier Ministre ici on
n'est pas vous vous le savez on n'est
pas au café du commerce on a une
commission d'enquête parlementaire donc
on s'amuserait pas je ne m'a pas ni en
éducation ni en morale ni juridiquement
à dire des choses sur des réunions ou
des choses qui ne sont pas vraies sommes
regarder nous sommes sous serment vous
êtes sous serment je suis président donc
je vous explique notre problématique de
réflexion sur le fiasco de la gestion
vous avez par le perplexité sur celle de
dépêche je veux bien reprendre à mon
compte ce propos puisque pareil vous
avez parlé d'une surveillance accrue qui
pour le coup c'est factuer n'a pas été
respecté concernant les deux en question
et l'acte en question d'accord donc je
reviens sur des faits donc l'effet je
suis pas en train de vouloir je pose des
questions que ce sont posées toute la
Corse et que nous sommes nous faisons
aussi un travail de pédagogie
de transparence et de démocratie à des
moments clés de basculement qui nous ont
fait rentrer dans un processus où on
sait où nous a conduit et à travers
l'acte et à travers les modulation qui
ont suivi donc c'est important si vous
me dites aujourd'hui de votre mémoire
vous ne vous rappelez plus d'ontact que
comme sur local est donné la vie
favorable à lever du statut des PS
concernant monsieur Allessandre mais que
vous dites que le parquet est intervenu
important dans ma mémoire j'avais je le
dis bien des avis défavorables dans le
premier cas c'est-à-dire celui de
Monsieur alessandrie et Ferrandi ce qui
va conduire prendre la décision du 12
janvier 2021
c'était pas le cas donc on n'aura pas la
réponse du pourquoi de la décision
contraire je passe la parole à Monsieur
rapporteur
merci monsieur le Président écoutez
monsieur le Premier ministre il y a des
questions qui vous ont été envoyées je
pense que vous avez préparé les réponses
dans un premier temps donc sur sur
d'éventuelles transmissions de consignes
de vous-même ou de ou de votre cabinet
bon vous auriez connaissance
concernant le maintien divan Colonna
vous avez plus ou moins répondu puisque
vous avez expliqué que vous êtes
conformé aux avis que vous receviez donc
j'imagine que à l'inverse vous n'avez
transmis aucune consigne dans ce sens
mais vous répondrez vous-même sur votre
sentiment sur la détention
d'Yvan Colonna
vous pourrez donner à votre avis puis
vous avez déjà répondu à la partie 5 sur
messieurs Ferrandi et alessandrie et
ensuite la sixième qui est qui fait
davantage appel à votre expérience
politique et administrative
eu égard assez fait et puis peut-être
qu'après je poser d'autres questions
puisque la la commission d'enquête la
vocation également à faire des
préconisations sur le suivi des tenues
radicalisées puisque il y a aussi la
partie Franck et longabais et la
problématique de la radicalisation en
prison et en détention vous avez eu
connaissance d'un certain nombre de
choses pendant votre exercice le Premier
ministre sur les politiques publiques
menées en la matière et également sur le
monde de la détention il y a des
rapports parlementaires qui ont été
publiés fort intéressant puisque ce qui
est aujourd'hui nous amène à être ici
c'est aussi et l'inspection que vous
avez commandé la équipe noire sur blanc
et votre successeur a rendu rapidement
instantanément public cette inspection
générale de la justice des défaillances
des défaillances qui au dire de
certaines personnes que nous avons
auditionné notamment des membres de
personnels de la pénitentiaire
ton qualifié de de
non isolés le fait générateur qui nous
amène à être présent ici à savoir il y a
beaucoup de violences en prison il y a
beaucoup d'agressions en prison
est-ce que aujourd'hui on regarde
l'expérience qui a été là votre en tant
que chef du gouvernement vous vous avez
un centre de préconisation d'avis à
rendre sur la législation actuelle et
les moyens mis à disposition notamment
du ministère de la justice concernant à
la vie pénitentiaire
je réponds tout de suite alors donc dans
les questions auxquelles je n'ai pas
répondu dans mon intervention luminaire
il y a donc la première monsieur
rapporteur comment avez-vous réagi à
l'agression mortelle du de mars 2022
avec stupeur quand j'apprends ça
évidemment c'est
c'est un sentiment à la fois
d'indignation et d'incompréhension
comment dans un univers qui est
l'univers pénitentiaire de telle fait
peuvent être qu'il commis d'autant que
j'apprends que les deux personnes la
personne agressée et l'agresseur a
également le statut de dps d'où ma
remarque de tout à l'heure sur le
caractère protecteur de ce statut
voilà donc je oui je suis sidéré de
d'apprendre c'est fait
pourquoi avoir refusé avant ce drame de
radis Yvan Colonna du répertoire des PS
je crois à monsieur le Président d'avoir
répondu à cette question tout à l'heure
avez-vous ou votre cabinet reçu ou
transmis des consignes avant cette même
date Visante à maintenir Ivan que l'on a
au répertoire des dps
on passe là aussi moi je vous indique
quand j'ai eu à statuer sur le cas de
Monsieur colonne et les dates auxquelles
je l'ai fait et je vous ai donné une
réponse exhaustive là-dessus avez-vous
le sentiment qui va en colonne a été
traité au cours de sa détention comme un
détenu de droit commun je n'ai pas
d'éléments de nature à pouvoir répondre
Monsieur Madame ce rapporteur à cette
question
voilà je ne je n'ai pas en tant que
Premier ministre
des détails aucun ne m'a jamais été en
tout cas porté à ma connaissance qui me
permettrait de donner une réponse
éclairée et justifier à cette question
la cinquième c'est pourquoi a-t-il fallu
attendre l'agression mortelle divan
commun pour lever le statut de dps
d'Alain Ferrandi et de Pierre
alessandrie donc et en quoi cet
événement a-t-il rendu absolument
au répertoire des pièces je crois cette
question m'a déjà été posée par le
président son propos liminaire et que
j'y ai apporté tout à l'heure la réponse
si ce qu'elles leçons direz-vous de
l'agression mortelle du 2 mars 2022
c'est causes au regard de votre
expérience souhaitez-vous formuler des
recommandations ou des préconisations à
la commission d'enquête alors les leçons
évidemment j'ai vous l'avez rappelé je
l'ai indiqué dans mon propos liminaire
immédiatement saisi l'inspection
générale de la justice pour que la
lumière soit faite indépendamment par
ailleurs de l'enquête d'instruction
pénale ouverte par les autorités
judiciaires et du travail de votre
commission donc on avait eu enfin ce qui
était convenu c'était que l'inspection
générale des services judiciaires
rendent un
rapport provisoire ce qu'elle a fait le
22 mars et je crois vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs monsieur porteur qu'elle a
rendu son rapport définitif en juin donc
je n'ai à un moment où je n'étais plus
Premier ministre l'appartenait donc à ma
successeur heureux de tirer toutes les
conséquences de cette affaire bon il y a
deux aspects d'un peut-être vraiment le
plus important pour moi qui rejoignent
notre échange monsieur pas assez c'est
ce statut de dps et la façon dont la
procédure est prévue par un décret et
une circulaire d'application je vous
dirais que ma recommandation puisque
c'est votre question monsieur rapporteur
en tout cas mon interrogation
c'est qu'on voit bien que dans ces
sujets se mêlent des décisions prises
par l'autorité judiciaire j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure des demandes liberté
conditionnelles et des décisions prises
par l'autorité administrative et ou
politique enfin dans la chaîne de
commandant on va dire traditionnel je
vous avoue que cela me laisse perplexe
et que puisque j'ai eu à les exercer
dans les conditions que vous avez formé
du reste
[Musique]
ce sont des décisions pour l'autorité
administrative enfin ou en tout cas
politique quand ça arrive à ce niveau
extrêmement difficile à prendre et que
je me demande s'il n'y aurait pas lieu
de faire évoluer le droit régissant le
statut de dps d'abord peut-être pour lui
donner un contenu plus précis car il ne
vous a pas échappé mesdames et messieurs
députés que ça résulte d'un décret mais
qui est dans le contenu pas très
consistant si vous me passez la formule
et qu'il renvoie à une circulaire donc
d'ailleurs je sais pas si c'est prêt
dans le rapporteur a rappelé les
principaux items je pense que ce droit
pourrait être revu et j'ouvre la
question devant vous
la décision ne devrait-elle pas plutôt
revenir au juge d'application des peines
à une autorité judiciaire bon d'abord
encore une fois parce que l'autorité
judiciaire intervient dans le process si
je puis dire de vie de la peine là je
m'extrais de ce cas je parle en général
et ensuite parce qu'elle a des
retentissements sur les décisions que
peut prendre l'autorité administrative
et enfin parce que bon ben évidemment
décision juridictionnelle peut se
contester comme les miennes l'ont été
évidemment mais peut-être que ça
objectiverait et Monsieur présence ça
éviterait ce genre de débat derrière
penser ou de ou de questionnements que
on peut se poser puisque comme vous
l'avez dit on est dans le champ d'un
avis de surcroît d'une commission qui
n'est pas elle-même décisionnelle donc
voilà ma principale recommandation à
l'endroit de cette commission en dehors
j'ai encore une fois du cas précis de
l'agression contre Monsieur colonne et
sans doute que l'on revoit et que alors
évidemment ça relève davantage
visiblement du poids réglementaire que
du pouvoir législatif mais
sauf si compte tenu déprogatives
d'autorité judiciaire le Parlement
souverainement décidé d'en confier la
responsabilité à juge auquel cas il me
semble que ça relèverait plutôt du
domaine de la loi alors il y a ensuite
la question de la radicalisation qu'il
en qui concerne cette fois-ci
l'agresseur évidemment l'agresseur bon
là c'est un sujet évidemment qui est
porté à ma connaissance
postérieurement à l'agression dont est
victime monsieur Colonna évidemment donc
je comment dire je c'est un fait
extérieur pour moi à la gestion de cette
affaire et effectivement qui amène mais
je pense et vous l'avez dit que
l'inspection générale la bien examinée
avoir tous les processus de lutte contre
la radicalisation prison j'ai vu que
l'Inspection Générale avait fait avait
formulé un certain nombre de
recommandations qui monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur me paraît
de bon aloi
monsieur Premier ministre avant de
passer la parole à Monsieur Castellane
qui qui l'a demandé je veux revenir sur
une question que je vous ai posé à
proposliminaire mais il me semble pas
que vous ayez répondu parce que
effectivement nous sommes là à la fois
pour travailler pour l'avenir dans le
recommandation
d'évolution des choses et nous le
faisons notre travail il me semble de
manière la plus honnête qui soit en la
matière c'est le sens notamment des
questions et des réponses que vous nous
apporter aux questions de Monsieur
rapporteur sur l'évolution potentielle
du statut des PS mais nous sommes aussi
là comme je l'ai évoqué pour regarder ce
qui s'est passé bien
dans le champ des travaux de la
commission sans implanter sur le quai du
judiciaire donc parmi la question vous
avez posé en question liminaire
mais suppo naketel devant cette audition
et d'autres acteurs nous affirmés qu'il
y a eu des discussions
nourries politiques entre entre
vous-même votre cabinet et les yeux de
la Corse fin 2021 début 2022 notamment
sur un tas de sujets cors évidemment pas
que ce sujet là mais notamment sur la
question des prisonniers
et notamment sur la question du
rapprochement familial à savoir que ce
rapprochement familial était posé sous
deux éléments soit la levée du statut de
dps soit et c'est dans cela que je
voudrais que vous éclairiez soit un
transfert possible après un processus
engagé d'aménagement du centre des
tensions de bord est-ce que vous pouvez
confirmer devant cette assemblée que ces
relations bien eu lieu
que des travaux des initiatives de
travaux ont bien été engagés et que
c'était bien à cette fin que ces travaux
étaient engagés
alors monsieur le Président oui des
discussions ont eu lieu à mon niveau sur
les questions relatives à la Corse en
général évidemment la question du statut
de dps je vous le confirme ont été
évoqué et je peux dire à la Commission
de façon très tranquille que les
réponses que j'ai faites évidemment nous
sommes bien d'accord tous ici avant
l'agression qui ont conduit à la mort de
Monsieur Colonna
et les réponses que j'avais faites sur
ce point précis mais vous avez raison de
dire qu'il y en avait d'autres dont j'ai
eu à connaître était conforme à celle
que j'ai faite devant votre commission
bon même si elles n'ont pas complètement
emporter la conviction de mes
interlocuteurs
mais ma partenaire de prendre mes
responsabilités je vous en ai donné
monsieur le Président les raisons sur le
rapprochement votre plus précisément et
Borgo
j'ai compris en prenant connaissance du
dossier effectivement que le statut de
dps imposait que ceux qui en font
l'objet ce dont nous parlons où les
autres soit incarcérés dans une maison
dite centrale c'est-à-dire
justifiant des équipements faisant
l'objet de la protection particulière
bon
la question de Borgo bien sûr monsieur a
été évoqué j'ai posé des questions et il
m'a été répondu que ça n'était pas une
maison centrale et qu'elle n'était pas
équipée dans ma mémoire mais là aussi je
vous invite à vérifier il me semble
qu'il y avait même un rapport de
l'Inspection générale
sans lien d'ailleurs avec ces faits mais
sur la prison de Borgo
qui confirmait que en droit
ou dans les faits ni en droit ni dans
les faits plus exactement elle ne
pouvait
ce qui suppose encore une fois j'essaie
d'être cohérent et moi-même la
conservation du statut de dps si dès
lors plus exactement que décision avait
été prise de conserver le statut de dps
des intéressés en l'état
il ne pouvait être transféré à Borgo bon
alors
l'idée je crois que c'est votre question
mais je veux ma nationalité de dire
est-ce que on pourrait aménager
la prison de Borgo pour qu'elle puisse
répondre à ces critères a été évoqué je
le dis devant votre commission j'ai
demandé à ce que on se penche sur cette
question
il m'a été répondu donc il faudrait
sûrement faire de lourds travaux etc et
moi je n'en ai parlé qu'avec mon cabinet
je précise que je n'ai jamais par
exemple parler de ça directement avec le
directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire que ce soit bien clair
mais si des échanges ont eu lieu je sais
pas quelle formule vous avez employé oui
et donc lorsque
arrive dans le début de 2022 je ne sache
pas que des travaux en tout cas visant à
satisfaire aux critères d'une maison
centrale
était engagée
sauf si vous avez des informations mais
en tout cas à ma connaissance non
alors je vous confirme que des marchés
ont été engagés je vous confirme
qu'effectivement qui sont dans la suite
l'inspection de fonctionnement nous fait
état d'octobre 2020 dont nous allons
nous procurer un certain nombre de
documents en termes de lettres de
mission et de conclusion qui a eu sur le
centre des tensions de bord ou lancer
sous votre gouvernement du moins par le
garde des sceaux qui faisait suite à
Madame beloubet donc ça c'est un point
important et que
je dirais contrairement à certaines
déclarations qui ont été faites ici par
d'autres acteurs pas d'autres acteurs
des marchés ont été lancés comme le
marché de la vidéo surveillance
notamment et du mirador qui devait faire
pour sécuriser le centre des tensions en
vue de y compris réaliser des quartiers
d'accueil de je cite des tenues
nationalistes corses donc
y compris pour en faire une maison
centrale susceptible d'accueillir des
dps on parle pas de maison centrale on
parle d'accueil il me semble que les
discussion que vous aviez vous dites si
c'est oui ou si c'est non c'était soit
on lève le statut dps vous avez
répondu même si on a un échange
contradictoire
soit le transfert possible et c'est le
sens de ma question c'est un engagement
potentiel de transfert c'est ça la
question que je vous pose si aménagement
réalisé
donc
c'est on est bien d'accord sur les
termes de la question et les termes de
l'engagement possible en fonction des
engagements réalisés et je vous confirme
que pardon puisque les mots comme vous
dites un sens j'ai compris jusqu'ici
enfin on m'a expliqué que pour pouvoir
retenir des
détenus au statut des PS il fallait
avoir le que la prison établissement
potentielle le statut de maison centrale
avec tout ce que soit ménager ou
aménager un quartier spécifique ce qui
était bon ça c'est très bien je vais
merci pour vos réponses je vais de la
parole à Monsieur Castellane
merci monsieur le Président ce premier
ministre j'aimerais revenir sur le sur
votre décision de ne pas lever le statut
de dps
puisque tous les événements qui ont
découlé de cette décision y compris des
événements tout à fait catastrophiques
et dramatique
cette décision de ne pas lever le statut
de dps et vous nous dites quel a été
prise uniquement en application des
textes qu'il n'y a pas eu de vengeance
d'État nous n'avons pas de raison de ne
pas vous croire
mais décision prise uniquement
l'application des textes mais vous nous
dites en même temps ça pose problème que
la période de sûreté était échue depuis
peu
mais monsieur Premier ministre une
période de sûreté échue depuis peu est
une période de sûreté et
donc est-ce que vous avez conscience que
vous n'avez pas comme vous le dites
appliquez les textes puisque
l'application des terres vous donnez
l'autorisation la permission le droit de
lever le statut de dps
ça nous pose un problème nous aimerions
vous entendre sur cette contradiction
merci
monsieur député je ne crois pas que ce
soit une contradiction mais vous me
permettrez quand même
de vraiment mais lever contre la
première partie de vos propos
les faits qui sont survenus en mars
2022 à présent d'Arles sont absolument
regrettables et condamnable ils étaient
totalement imprévisible et dire qu'il
découle devant de ma décision de refuser
le statut de dps de Monsieur Colonna
je suis désolé de vous dire que je le
conteste absolument formellement bon
deuxièmement sur votre question
que disent les textes ils disent pas non
plus mais c'est ça nous renvoie au sujet
de forme monsieur député si la loi
disait dès lors que la période de sûreté
est échu alors
on ne peut plus où il faut lever le
statut de dps mais c'est pas ce que dit
la loi ni les textes pris pour son
application alors on peut le regretter
c'est comme ça bon et quand à la
référence à la période de sûreté qui
était tout juste et si j'y ai fait
moi-même référence parce que de mémoire
la commission donnant un avis sur ce
sujet le mentionne dans ses motifs de
rejet c'est tout je vous dis pas que de
manière je ne fais pas d'appréciation
qualitative c'est factuel bon et donc
sur la question de principe encore une
fois moi je pense
que pour l'avenir puisque le président
vient dire l'éclairage du passé et les
conséquences qu'on peut en tirer pour
l'avenir je pense qu'il faut que la loi
et le poids réglementaire
encadre davantage peut-être judiciarise
davantage objective davantage la notion
d'inscription ou de non-inscription au
statut de dps mais au cas d'espèces
encore une fois s'agissant de Monsieur
colonne j'ai encore une fois à mon ami
conscience au vu des faits et du droit
et je tiens à le répéter parce que j'ai
un immense respect pour la Corse
je n'ai pris ces décisions que pour les
motifs que je vous ai indiqué et
monsieur le Président je le dis très
clairement pour aucun autre
aucun autre
très clairement
nous reviendrons sur ces éléments là
encore un peu parce que ça va nous
occuper pour solder cette histoire
malheureuse et dramatique je crois que
madame lui a demandé la parole
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre je vais revenir à
nouveau sur la décision que vous avez
prise notamment concernant donc le
statut de dps des de ces messieurs
Ferrandi et Alexandrie
notamment vous avez cité le fait de vous
souvenir
David défavorable donc de la levée de
ces statuts est-ce que vous souvenez les
avoir lu vous-même ou est-ce que cette
information vous est parvenu à l'oral
par peut-être votre directeur de cabinet
ou quelqu'un d'autre
dans vos souvenirs d'où venait cette
information précisément et quel par quel
biais vous l'avez reçu je vous remercie
par banque cabinet pas par bon directeur
ça c'est que je vois très bien les
conseillers qui étaient en charge de ce
sujet mais par mon cabinet oui bien sûr
comme il est d'usage
avez-vous lu vous même les documents
dont il ne s'agissait ou pas je comme
j'ai retrouvé dans mes dossiers puisque
je prête sincèrement là la vie de la
Commission concernant monsieur colonne
puisque de surcroît l'objet de votre
commission
concerne l'effet dont il a été victime
celle-là je l'ai retrouvé donc si je
laisse c'est qu'à l'époque je l'ai lu et
ça j'en suis sûr l'autre je ne peux pas
vous répondre de manière catégorique
aujourd'hui je ne sais plus si je l'ai
lu ou si comme le l'introduisait à votre
question il m'en a été fait relation
monsieur le rapporteur peut-être
ce serait peut-être une pièce qu'on
pourrait demander pour des pièces à
posteriori de l'audition je vous
remercie prends note la demande on va on
voit comment la traiter
je crois que Monsieur Colomba il a
demandé de la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
encore son doigt absolument à travers
ses auditions sortir la théorie des
complots pour
je veux dire
mettre à plat tous les
dysfonctionnements
on doit expliquer au corps et pas encore
ça comment
détenus a pu être agressé sauvagement
sous les yeux de
cinquantaine de caméras si je dis pas de
bêtises pendant plus de 12 minutes avec
un parcours avec un des nôtres détenus
qui a un parcours
absolument hallucinant dans ces prisons
je me parlais de la
sur ce parcours sur ce parcours nous on
s'interroge toujours sur ce maintien du
statut des PS parce que depuis que nous
sommes arrivés au Parlement avec mes
collègues à quoi vivre le Castellane
2017 nous avons cessé de demander nous
avons passé de demander la levée de ce
statut de dps qui aurait permis de
ramener ces détenus encore nous avons
été rejoints tout doucement par d'autres
groupes du Parlement
Bruno Quetel François coupon ils ont
passé ses intervenir à nos côtés
Jean-Jacques Ferrara c'était une demande
de transpartisane et de 2017 à 2020 la
commission locale c'est systématiquement
présente
systématiquement prononcé pour la levée
du statut de dps en 2020 fait
exceptionnel c'est le premier ministre
cette commission ne se réunit pas
en 2022 on a la stupeur de voir que
cette commission aura un avis selon que
l'on se place sur mesure pour vous pour
vous permettre de dire que le statut de
dps il faut le maintenir alors qu'aucun
fait de dangerosité n'a été
rapporté il n'y a pas d'éléments
nouveaux il y a pas d'incident en prison
et donc ça fait partie des éléments
qu'on a besoin de clarifier encore une
fois je reviens encore sur ce sujet là
que mes collègues ont déjà soulevé parce
que ça permettrait de lever cette
théorie du complot
monsieur député vous dites en 2022
oui
encore une fois moi je sois clair moi je
ne parle pas au commissions enfin je
voilà et les décisions je vous je
reviens pas je dis je les prends à mon
homme et conscience au vu de l'ensemble
des éléments du dossier et vous avez là
où je vous rejoins parfaitement il faut
purger la théorie du complot
et là où vous pouvez dire qu'il y a
effectivement
dysfonctionnement grave c'est ce qui
s'est passé à la maison d'arrêt d'Arles
incontestablement bon ensuite
l'application
des
règles régissant le statut de dps
la façon dont je l'ai mise en œuvre et
évidemment oui je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi j'ai évolué au fait et c'était
pas un petit chambre des fait très grave
qui se sont produits en mars 2022 cette
cette question là
me paraît avoir été appliqué sur la base
de critères rationnel
on peut ne pas être d'accord avec moi
mais ce que je veux vraiment garantir
c'est moi qui est pris décision même
c'est moi un autre c'est moi
à aucun cas je veux le dire à vous et
par de la vous comme la rappeler le
Président je ne suis animé pas la
moindre vengeance le moindre complot
mais ça je vous avais raison il faut
complètement enlever ça de l'esprit de
chacune et de chacun voilà bon encore
une fois est-ce que au vu de tout ça
pour ce cas particulier ou pour d'autres
cette procédure de liste de dps est
parfaite
sûrement pas est-ce qu'il faut
l'améliorer je me suis comme mien vite
tel rapporteur essayez à quelques
propositions bon mais leur application
des règles existantes je parle au cas
d'espèce encore une fois
ne me paraissent pas et en tout cas je
veux que vous en soyez convaincu relever
d'autres
sentiments dimensions ou objectif que ce
que j'ai
dans j'ai rendu compte devant votre
commission ce député
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres questions
[Musique]
on parle d'une personne qui a un profil
très particulier c'est un soldat
islamiste qui est sur le même statut que
que d'autres dps il était dangereux il
était renfermé sur lui-même il avait
fait preuve de à multiples reprises d'un
comportement agressif y compris au
niveau des gardiens et au niveau des
autres détenus et pourtant il était dans
une ce qu'on pourrait appeler une marche
forcée vers la sortie accompagnée de
manière à ce qu'ils puissent
pour voir y compris un poste
d'auxiliaire qu'il avait qu'il avait
obtenu à la suite de cette affaire donc
on a vu les conséquences à la suite de
cette affaire vous avez dit tout à
l'heure que vous aviez saisi
l'igsp l'IGS
pour pour voilà pour faire une situation
un point sur cette situation mais c'est
pas le seul monsieur long Gabet qui
aujourd'hui est dans dans des maisons
centrales il y en a d'autres il y a
d'autres et longs gavés qui sont dans le
même dans le même cadre est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut mettre en place un
dispositif particulier pour ce type de
profil et peut-être je sais pas
conditionner leur sortie parce que là
c'est des personnes qui sont
susceptibles de d'être voilà de sortir à
la fin de leur peine ce qui dans un état
de droit est normal mais là selon ces
profils là on sait que derrière on voit
que derrière on constate que le danger
reste le même que lorsqu'ils sont
rentrés
réponse factuelle évidemment mais ça la
commission n'en doute pas je n'ai jamais
entendu parler de Monsieur elonga B
avant qu'il commette l'effet dont nous
parlons cet après-midi jamais bon donc
vous avez raison de rappeler dès que ces
derniers sont portés à ma connaissance
je saisis l'inspection générale des
services du ciel et je le rappelle quand
même une instruction pénale est ouverte
je suppose toujours en cours dont nous
espérons tous qu'elle fera très
clairement la lumière sur ce qui s'est
passé et sur l'identification des
responsabilités et des suites pénales
que ces dernières méritent bon et dès
lors évidemment ai-je besoin de rappeler
à la commission que cette instruction
pénale est déclenchée évidemment le le
gouvernement ne peut plus interférer
donc il y a cette enquête j'en ai lu bon
les conclusions présentées mais surtout
les conclusions définitives j'étais plus
Premier ministre il me ensemble qu'aux
question que vous posez elles apportent
des réponses à la fois plus précises et
plus circonstanciées que je ne saurais
le faire et effectivement elles mettent
en évidence qu'il y a un sujet qui est
un sujet qui dépasse puisque j'ai bien
compris tel était votre question le cas
d'espèces bon et donc il faut évidemment
me semble-t-il et ça appartient
notamment à l'administration
pénitentiaire et à la représentation
nationale comme on dit chacun à ceux qui
les concerts de tirer là aussi
toutes les conséquences notamment sur le
comportement des personnes radicalisées
ou par ailleurs des personnes présentant
des troubles psychiques susceptibles
d'être dangereux
en milieu carcéral
monsieur le rapporteur merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
je voudrais
revenir sur
sur le contexte en réalité la question
de mon collègue colombagne
[Musique]
je dirais rappeler que effectivement
suite à l'agression dans Yves en colonne
a été victime
des femmes et des hommes encore de tout
bord politique confondus j'assise
vraiment sur cela on
émis Amy à sa zone de d'hypothèses qui
relevé de la théorie du complot c'est
important de le rappeler parce que
d'abord je suis le seul député non
nationaliste de la Corse dans cette
assemblée je me demande de la majorité
présidentielle et mon parcours politique
s'est inscrit
uniquement dans la famille de la droite
républicaine et pour ma part j'ai vécu
depuis
allez 25 ans puisque nous avons
commémoré le 25e
anniversaire de l'assassinat de Monsieur
préfet cette cette histoire en tant que
militant
non nationaliste
cette commission elle a une vocation
effectivement à faire des préconisations
c'est une commission d'enquête mais elle
a aussi une vocation politique citoyenne
majeure et et moi je voulais vraiment
revenir là-dessus pourquoi est-ce que
cette question est posée chez le Premier
ministre vous le savez parce que les
rapports entre l'accord et l'État ont
parfois été conflictuel
et que il a été démontré par la justice
que parfois des agents de l'État étaient
susceptibles d'y connaître des fautes
lourdes des délits des crimes et que
dans le cœur de l'ensemble des corps ce
qu'il soit nationaliste ou pas cela a
laissé beaucoup de meurtrissures pour ça
que cette question revient
et c'est pour ça que en tant que en tant
que député mais aujourd'hui ce que je
voudrais encore une fois vous dire c'est
pour que vous le répétiez parce que je
crois que la latitude de la pédagogie
c'est aussi l'art de la répétition c'est
que dans le cadre de l'exercice de vos
responsabilités parce que vous avez été
également quand même directeur adjoint
secrétaire général adjoint de l'Élysée
sous Nicolas Sarkozy que vous avez
exercer la responsabilité de chef du
gouvernement de notre pays
de dire ce que vous avez à répondre à
celles et ceux qui de bonne foi encore
ou ailleurs considère que les événements
qui sont produits le 2 mars à Arles
étaient d'une manière ou d'une autre
soit par le pouvoir politique soit par
le pouvoir administratif sur la partie
judiciaire je vous dirai qu'à titre
personnel il faudrait une petite insert
puisque pouvoir judiciaire est
indépendant dans d'autres pays il rend
des décisions souverainement dont du
peuple français je me suis fait quand
même à l'idée quand même qu'elle avait
un traitement particulier des hommes qui
avaient été condamnés je suis avocat de
profession donc peut-être c'est une
déformation de ma part que certaines
décisions de justice revêtait un
caractère assez particulier notamment
sur les maintiens de certains statuts
à gravité
que personne ne dit gravité extrême des
faits qui les ont amenés à être
emprisonnés condamnés mais voilà je
voudrais vraiment insister sur le fait
de parler responsabilités imminentes que
vous avez exercées au service de l'État
que il n'y a pas eu à votre connaissance
d'intervention politique
administrative de ce que certains
peuvent parfois
qualifier ici ou ailleurs d'État profond
en vue de de permettre la survenance de
cet événement dramatique qui vous le
savez à eu pour conséquence de créer de
graves troubles à l'ordre public
vous en avez eu connaissance et pour
cause puisque le préfet de Corse actuel
était dans mon bureau au moment où vous
l'appelez
parce que j'étais maire d'Ajaccio à
l'époque lorsque les premiers incidents
à Ajaccio survenus et il s'en est fallu
de très peu selon moi pour que des
drames irréparables de ce produisent
dans la période qui a suivi l'agression
qui a coûté la vie divin colonne donc le
gars la gravité cette situation et aux
questions que de braves gens de tout
bord se pose permet encore de d'assister
sur cette question
oui merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez raison nous parlons
de fait très grave départ l'assassinat
d'un préfet de la République
[Musique]
l'agression très grave qui s'est
produite en univers carcéral tout ça
rien de tout ça n'est banal tout ça est
grave et je comprends l'émotion tout ce
que vous dites et je n'ai pas attendu de
venir devant vous pour l'entendre et le
comprendre j'avais été interrogé y
compris cher monsieur le Président dans
le cadre de question gouvernement où
cette question du complot avait déjà été
évoqué vous m'avez fait venir
aujourd'hui ce président mesdames
vous dites les braves gens je reprends
votre formule monsieur rapporteur
s'interroge se pose des questions
je crois monsieur le reporter faire
partie des braves gens
j'ai exercé la responsabilité éminente
de chef du gouvernement de la République
j'ai eu dans les circonstances qu'on a
rappelé le déport c'est comme ça c'est
la vie à intervenir directement dans le
dossier
de toute façon après compte tenu de la
dimension très forte des troubles à
l'ordre public que vous avez rappelé qui
se sont produits après l'agression puis
le décès d'Yvan Colonna le Premier
ministre quel qu'il fut aurais-tu en
connaître j'avais le président y a fait
référence des discussions sur des sujets
relatifs à la Corse en dehors en dehors
de la question des PS donc on va dire je
ne découvre rien de ce que vous me dites
mais
je crois connaître l'état
je crois connaître l'état j'ai beaucoup
de respect pour l'État je veux dire ici
solennellement que
non seulement
je n'ai jamais ni de près ni de loin en
ce sujet comme dans les autres étaient
l'instrument de moindres complot
je me demande d'ailleurs bien à quelle
finalité mais que je n'avais eu ni de
près ni de loin jamais vous m'entendez
bien connaissance et que si elle avait
été le cas je demande à la Commission
parce que vous connaissez par ailleurs
jamais je n'aurais plutôt écarté dessus
t'étais un grave abaissement de l'État
un grave abaissement de l'État voilà
donc je répète la commission j'ai pris
dans ce que je pense être l'intérêt de
l'État et de la paix sociale ovule des
faits et de l'ensemble des éléments à ma
disposition les décisions que j'ai crues
de voir prendre je vous ai amené
expliquer les motivations
et
ce qui s'est passé est évidemment
l'enchaînement des circonstances que
vous avez rappelé évidemment extrêmement
douloureux
nous devons effectivement profiter de ce
moment pour tout nous dire
en tirer s'il y a lieu des conséquences
on en a évoqué un certain nombre plus
structurel mais voilà
de complots d'état ou contre le chocolat
ou à fortiori contre la Corse je
réaffirme ici à ma qualité d'anciens
chef du gouvernement de la République
qu'il n'y a pointu et heureusement
monsieur le Premier j'ai pas prévu de
prendre la parole à ce stade mais je
pense que on est dans un moment
important où il faut se dire comme vous
dites toutes les choses
avant de laisser la parole à Madame
agressérobach qui l'a demandé et à
l'aune de la fin de cette audition qui
avance qui approche
je pense qu'il faut rendre la dignité
aux gens dans ce moment que nous vivons
nous sommes de ceux
et compris avec nos convictions avec
notre histoire les uns les autres
qui avons toujours
toujours
en tout temps en tout lieu rendu la
dignité
aux membres de la famille en tout temps
tout lieu quelques études parce que nous
savons
dans une société de proximité ce qu'est
la mort d'un homme dans une famille
nous savons ça peut impliquer en terme
de drame
je voudrais aussi rendre la dignité à la
famille des vents colonnes parce que
vous quand je suis dans ces débats là je
le surjoue pas j'ai une image en tête
j'ai l'image ce petit garçon de 10 ans
au milieu des gens noyés sous le monde
qui tient fort la main de sa mère
à l'enterrement d'un père qui n'a vu que
quelques fois
que les yeux en bués à gare il ne sait
pas où il va
chez les yeux du deuxième du premier
fils qui se sert la mâchoire j'ai les
yeux aussi de du père malade et de la
mère qui n'a pas vu son fils depuis 15
ans
il n'avait pas le droit
de subir la double peine il n'avait pas
le droit
dans un soi-disant État de droit de
subir la double peine
l'État ne peut pas dire ni sous votre
gouvernement ni sous les gouvernements
précédents
qu'il n'y avait pas de demande de
rapprochement familial fondé
qu'il n'y avait pas de demande
d'aménagement fondée vous avez parlé
d'un coup important je peux vous
garantir que le coup n'est pas important
il est le sur 50 à 200.000 euros pour
l'aménagement de centre des tensions de
bord que ça se savait ça c'est le
premier point et ensuite je vais aller
plus loin monsieur le Premier ministre
je vais pas vous mettre en cause
personnellement c'est pas ça l'enjeu
quand je n'ai pas là
nous sommes députés
je vais dire moi ce que j'ai entendu
dans les couloirs sans travailler en
n'importe quel secret de discussion que
j'ai eu à avoir personnellement mais que
les deux autres ont eu aussi avec moi
concernant ces détenus parce
qu'effectivement on trouvera pas dans
les critères dps de capacité à pouvoir
dire
il faut qu'il soit rapproché parce que
la fait sa peine de sûreté
les critères des PS sont suffisamment
larges
suffisamment larges c'est le propos de
Laurent Ridel pour qu'on puisse ouvrir
le parapluie et dire ils ont été
condamnés ils restent des PS quelque
soit leur évolution pas de problème
c'est écrit on reste là on voit le
parapluie la vérité des propos que nous
avons eu parce qu'on aurait pu prendre
la décision inverse durant toutes ces
années on peut prendre malgré les
critères d'épaisse l'idée de lever ou de
transférer ces personnes on ne le
faisait pas parce qu'il y avait la
promesse de ne pas le faire parce qu'il
y avait une promesse de ne pas le faire
c'est moi qui parle
c'est moi qui parle en raison du
traumatisme l'assassinat préféré en
raison de l'extrême n je vous donne une
chose claire monsieur le Premier
ministre et parce que j'ai un peu
d'éducation je vais pas aller au bout
mais on pourrait le faire parce que
c'est pas vraiment l'enjeu
le lendemain de la venue du général
Darmanin encore
lorsqu'il y a eu les drames nous avons
été en possession de messages entre
préfet en exercice vous entendez ce que
je vais vous dire entre préfère
l'exercice qui disent qu'il fallait
décorer long à B qui disent qu'il a fait
ce qu'ils auraient dû faire depuis bien
longtemps vous entendez ce que je dis
alors de me dire pour rendre la dignité
la famille de mon colonne
qui n'a jamais eu de haine contre ses
membres là qui avait donné au-delà du
droit et que dans les propos oraux
pouvaient nicher l'arbitraire pour qu'il
soit jamais rapproché et encore moins
libéré même s'ils avaient de bons
dossiers d'aménagement de peine confère
confère les appels systématiques du
ministère public et le parquet national
antiterroriste d'ailleurs décisions
cassée par la Cour de cassation et de
finnée sur le le fumeux trouble alors au
public qui n'existait pas parce que
c'était le trou en public venait de leur
nom libération et pas de l'inverse
on arrive enfin à prêter de moult
discussion à ce que l'aménagement de
peine suivent le chemin du droit cette
haine a existé elle a existé et ça c'est
rendre la dignité la famille de mon
colonne parceciédarité que nous avons
rencontré et je vais même aller plus
loin vous pouvez dire non Monsieur le
Premier Ministre ça n'enlèvera pas les
réunions que j'ai eu et les sujets de
personnes je vais la même plus loin dans
le processus c'était 2 et 1
on traite peut-être les deux lui plus
tard en raison du fait qu'il n'avait
jamais à vous avouer être le tireur et
en raison du fait qu'il contestait
toujours son innocence et heureusement
le fait qu'il venait des démarches
devant le cours européenne de justice en
cours avec ses avocats donc ça c'est moi
qui parle à un moment charnière ici on
doit surtout se dire comme vous dites
pour commander tout ce qu'on puisse se
dire on considère pas que les gens sont
fous en disant complot en disant que la
haine n'existe pas et pour rendre la
dignité à des gens qui a eu triple peine
la peine de celui qui fait sa peine
normal la peine familiale de ce qui
n'avaient pas subir la peine et de leur
explosion familiale et de leur maladie
et qu'on sort et des fils qui n'auront
plus de père et la peine de la mort
infinie voilà ça factuellement quels
étaient les rouages avec transfert de
responsabilité dans une démocratie aux
états de droit concernant l'histoire où
les choses ont été posées à maintes
reprises si on n'aurait jamais dû
exister jamais tout en respectant la
douleur à la famille jamais voilà je le
dis parce que j'entends des propos et
chacun parle avec sa façon et je
respecte pour les hommes mais je peux
pas laisser passer à cet homme de choses
quand on sait ce qu'on a entendu ce
qu'on a vécu est-ce qu'on a lu
je vais être très clair j'ai l'éducation
qui me vient de loin et je ne dis pas
les choses au hasard je n'ai pas les
choses au hasard et je pense que vous
savez mais je vous demande pas de
réponse je vous donne pas de réponse que
cette promesse elle a existé voilà
madame Sagres
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur Monsieur le Premier Ministre
ma question est en réalité assez simple
mais plutôt technique puisque toutes les
décisions étaient fondées notamment la
vôtre sur le statut de dps donc sur une
commission qui statue sur le fait qu'on
puisse laisser quelqu'un ou pas dps ne
pensez vous pas et là c'est pour
enrichir le travail législatif parce que
je pense que cette commission doit
donner naissance à des et c'est le tout
le sens même je pense de notre travail
donner naissance à des évolutions
législatives c'est en tout cas le sens
de mon engagement de pensez-vous pas
finalement
qu'il serait peut-être plus judicieux et
vraiment je m'adresse à l'ancien Premier
ministre plus judicieux que finalement
cette décision de laisser de maintenir
quelqu'un ou pas dans le statut dps
plutôt au juge d'application des peines
finalement qu'à une commission qui en
réalité assez éloignée que ce soit sur
le plan
juridique mais aussi sur le plan
émotionnel parce que nous ne sommes
infinés que de pauvres êtres humains
face à tout ce qui se passe donc voilà
vraiment je m'adresse à notre ancien
Premier ministre parce que je pour moi
c'est un vrai sujet et merci de votre
réponse
merci mamela d'éviter il me semble sous
contrôle du président et rapporteur que
j'ai déjà répondu à cette question pour
vous dire qu'effectivement
personnellement je retiens de cette
affaire que le droit qui encadre les dps
mériteraient d'évoluer c'était
contestablement un enseignement que Jean
retire bon que j'ai essayé d'articuler
les motifs qui m'ont conduit à faire
cette préconisation tout à l'heure vous
me permettrez donc de ne pas les répéter
toutefois puisque le rapporteur a évoqué
l'état de droit
j'ai agi dans le cadre de l'État de
droit et lorsque je faisais une
dénégation au président
qui m'a dit je ne sollicite pas de
réponse de votre part je veux simplement
lui dire que
pas plus que le complot c'est moi que
vous avez devant vous aujourd'hui la
haine n'a jamais guidé cette matière
commandante mais je suis là devant vous
pour parler de ce dossier les décisions
que j'ai eu la responsabilité de prendre
et il faut effectivement que tout cela
s'apaise
il fait effectivement je souhaite que ce
soit aussi leur rapporteur parlait de
vocation pédagogique de votre commission
le rôle de votre travail
je vais me permettre une poser une
question quand même liée à
des choses
vous savez que vous vous avez pris
connaissance même la justice vous avez
eu à prendre connaissance à ton
dysfonctionnement grave je vous cite
concernant ce qu'il s'est passé
là-dessus
nous avons été
récemment destinataire nations de
documents qui nous pose question
et il se peut
que des fautes plus lourdes encore que
ce que prévoit l'inspection Géral
justice allez on va dire ça de manière
un peu mécanique des fourtes lourdes
systémiques
avec des enchaînements d'action
peut-être ou d'actes de nuisances
voit le jour
en Suisse donc les conclusions
d'inspection
je veux parler de l'interrogation par
exemple que nous avons à vivre en ce
moment de savoir si lorsqu'on nous
transfère le logiciel Genesis dans
lequel les agents
la pénitentiaire remette toutes les
observations quotidiennes concernant
Franck elongabe depuis 2014 la plus
petite savoir si je laissais pousser la
barbe à la conversation qu'il avait
telle ou telle détenue et puis au bout
d'un moment à partir de 29 janvier 2022
il y a plus d'observation
0 jusqu'à jusqu'au drame 0
ce qui est très grave parce que soit il
y a des faux transmission ça peut se
résoudre soit ça veut dire qu'il y a eu
un effacement de données
il n'y a pas d'autres solutions de la
vue des été moins que nous avons eu
encore à avoir devant nous
donc tout cela pour vous informer que
dans cette dans cette processus que nous
avons à vivre
ma question repose sur la question sur
votre avis je vous demande un avis un
des éléments de contradiction autre
celui que je viens d'évoquer vient du
fait que nous le savons aujourd'hui
Franck alongabé était connu des services
de renseignement comme étant je cite
extrêmement dangereux
aguerri aux armes de guerre
ayant pris par à des actes à des
attaques contre les forces
coalisées en Afghanistan et donc qu'il
était ce qu'on appelle eau du spectre ou
haut du pavé des terroristes islamistes
donc nous avons cette photographie qui
nous est donnée par les services de
renseignement et nous avons l'autre
photographie
qui nous amène à avoir un individu
notre y compris notifié comme
schizophrène par les autorités
américaines et autorités françaises et
de renseignements en plus d'être
dangereux
qui est mis dans le circuit de ma marche
quasiment forcée qu'elle était les
incidents qui les plus commettre
de la détention ordinaire et puis même
avoir un emploi en service général
est-ce que de votre avis dans cette un
avis que je vous demande est-ce que vous
considérez que il était normal que l'on
n'est pas transféré comme le lien
section gérant la justice
Frank Elong aberranquère en quartier
d'évaluation est-ce qu'ils étaient
normales cette connaissance que nous
avons fine aujourd'hui de son extrait
dangerosité qu'il était qu'il y a à
avoir un emploi en service général
tel que vous comprenez monsieur pas moi
j'ai pas connaissance de tous les faits
que vous venez de rapporter
moi les ma seule connaissance des faits
résulte du rapport et encore une nerveux
que la version provisoire du rapport
d'inspection générale bon et les faits
qui sont déjà rapportés là qui ne sont
pas de l'intensité ou de la nature de
ceux que vous venez d'indiquer sont déjà
très graves bon donc vraiment je peux
pas donner un avis sur des faits que je
découvre là ce que je dis il y a des
suites pénales il y a votre commission
d'enquête il y a une inspection générale
il faut tirer soit pour les personnes
concernées soit pour le fonctionnement
du système tous les enseignements tous
les enseignements que cette dramatique à
faire appel dans la transparence et dans
la clarté tous les enseignements
bien je me trouve mes collègues ce qu'il
y a d'autres questions monsieur le
rapporteur
je crois que nous allons donc mettre un
terme à cette audition